[Musica]
ufficialmente era di smart times o
singola challenger fighissima
divertentissima trova il gatto cialde
ma non solo i gattoni può trovare perché
gli altri animali nascosti
andiamo a fare questi puzzle regole
semplicissime avete 30 secondi per ogni
immagine per trovare il gatto o gli
animali nascosti
ogni immagine io sarò un numero 2 dove
potete scrivere in cui 30 se con i miei
commenti dove il gatto all animale così
giocherete assieme a me e poi alla fine
del video vediamo qualche conti ho fatto
io quando studiavo the fatto fuori
vediamo se ho dentro se avete vinto voi
che siete più forti di me se si sembrano
fortini mente vediamo se questa volta
riesco a non dimenticare che tutti i
numeri a tenere tutto il conto sia dei
punti che delle immagini comunque siete
pronti io sono prontissimo non dover
giocare con voi prendete i popcorn
patatine mettete il video tutto schermo
perché dovete concentrarvi sull'immagine
juve lo metterò bella grande terrore ed
entrare a far parte della storia esterni
vi basta iscrivervi ottima regia tipiche
e lasciare un ex questo video sopra
degli altri video giochi divertenti e
ben bernake arrivare a tutti pronti
entriamo
ok ragazzi concentriamoci immagine il
numero 1 abbiamo trenta secondi per
trovare il cazzo siete pronti via ostile
trofei
[Musica]
nessun che sta avvenendo latte con il
timer che la programma rimasta numero
uno di piatto stava al centro quindi era
mimetizza tissimo ok ok numero due
siete pronti proviamo il gatto qua
attenzione 31 via addio
allora forse quel mezzo c'è qualcosa di
dove sei gatti 31 neanche questo numero
due il gatto era a destra cosa ha fatto
quello che era a destra
delle pietre numero 3 oddio è
impossibile trovarlo qua gatto forse
perché questa ciò lenti come anche un
punto la prima volta nella numero 3
chimica era a sinistra al centro numero
4 da questa volta tanto non lo posso
fare questo e questo no diciamo che 8
cosa fa pietà
[Musica]
non si credono numero 4 st opposto corto
non vederlo numero 5 quest'immagine che
stretta non riusciamo a trovarlo
ecco come come tutto è molto minore
ecco pronto un avete già scuola con
quello abbiamo trovato assieme
ecco qua il primo numero 58 finalmente
più primo punto è più farsi vedere le
immagini più piccole ora magari chi si e
caricato dall'altra fa poiché è viva o
un punto vediamo la prossima numero 6
no forse un robot oddio
[Musica]
[Applauso]
scrivetelo ovviamente voi ce l'avete
trovato nei commenti numero space spa
destra sinistra centro crede vediamo
come modo mi mette tanti membri bene
numero 7
oddio c'è troppo casino e questo è
troppo difficile trovarlo non vedo
nessun caso
[Musica]
no è impossibile non trovo vediamo come
sta non credo di tutto numero 8
[Musica]
niente controllo sicuramente il massimo
dalle rocce sull'albero questo qualcosa
numero 8 si poteva attendere per come ho
fatto a nome naruto numero 9
[Musica]
vero ma non impossibile
spero perché sono più punti di mail
numero 9 si può far niente ma non lo
dissi qua bisogna trovare il leopardo
non è il gatto ok ok questo che faccio
perché non era un gattino comunque salvo
a due punti almeno due punti adesso e
non solo uno quindi numero 10 a sinistra
a destra è matto ok ragazzi il prossimo
in questo non bisogna trovare il gatto
ma vari animali quindi forse per sempre
in sempre piegate su dimenticano
infatti ho fatto solo un punto in questo
dei gatti allora in questo bisogna
trovare in questo primo quindi fus che
il numero 11 per noi dobbiamo provare
l'uccello vediamo
ok io l'ho già trovato il che mi sembra
strano che sia così difficile così
facile forse perché non mi sono taccole
tutti i cd stimo delegati comunque
guardate bene
correte bene
trovate anche momento a poco vieni qui è
dove ho trovato dai questa è facile
anche se se si mimetizza beh tra le
foglie questo spazio
allora vi dico dove l'ho trovata io qua
e con quale delirio ha mai opposto tre
punti almeno
forse questo è più facile ora
recuperiamo un po di punti numero di
todi si trova il cavallo ok
l'ho trovato quello di coppa poco
guardate bene dappertutto anche nei
posti menù pensati per bene che in
quattro punti che meglio mi piace questo
gioco mi è stato sempre salire con il
colucci numero 3 di si trova in gruppo
ok ma l'ho già trovato sono passati da
quello super difficile dei gatti e
questo focsiv e quindi speriamo dunque
di punti
io trovate mi un pò guardate bene quante
bene non riuscirete a di ritorno anche
voi ho visto io
pronti via l'altro motto qua
risalta abbastanza bene quindi sala 5
punti store che anche questo
interessamento prendono i punti dopo i
gatti impossibili da trovare numero 14
quasi alla fine trova corso ok questo è
un po più difficile credo nessun orso
non lo trovo
nessuno però l'ha trovato nulla
ma cosa me ma io mi aspettavo però ora
sono un immane di rotta degli alberi non
è tutto
[Musica]
come ci fa paura allora tutti inter fu
cacciato tutto bene si sono spostate le
luci mi sono spaventata perché io già
leggere un altro video che ci sono delle
presenze estranee questa casa ma non mi
dilungo troppo perché non voglio troppo
andare fuori argomento finiamo in prima
la challenge primo letto di un altro
video che ne parlo meglio datemi sapesse
di inter e di quali presenze stop
comunque continuiamo a datalogic e
quadri linda numero 15 bisogna trovare
il gatto fa sicuramente sarà più
difficile contro lo sapevo si
mimetizzano troppo belli gli occhi
allora lì e sono 52 punti
[Musica]
una ragazza da nessuna parte
vediamo un po cosa identico colore della
maglia numero 16 trova il fanta a mio
figlio è impossibile guardate quanti
film quindi dire ok
guardiamo bene con strisce di pinguini
l'ho trovato qua ci posso credere che un
metro e salvo a 6 punti wow fantastico
numero 17 con questa mattina è trovata
alla ok basta farci qualche loro genio
di droga almeno penso che sia una
valutazione a foglia una farfalla
comunque tra poco quello dico guardate
bene perché è riusciti ad individuarla
anche voi sembra una foglia
in realtà detto che sino a farla il
ricordo più quanti punti stavo 67
comunque ho trovato la farfalla qua vi
diamo è stato per una farfalla o delle
favole
[Musica]
quindi salvo a 7 punti mi sembra numero
18 trova in cane
oddio queste immagini enormi e
impossibile
si no
[Musica]
ancora avete fatto dire negli anni vi
rimane fino chiede per sé negli ampi
numero 19 trova il serpente
ok nostro porto ragazze tutto matto
guardate bene ancora che bene si
monetizza bene però se morte bensì di te
ok ti dico dove l'ho trovato qui al
centro vedete che il colore leggermente
diverso vediamo se si stava 8 punti
incredibile con questo gioco ho
recuperato numero 10 che dovrebbe essere
l'ultimo
e attorno il numero 20 scusate trova il
ragno silos trovate anche in grande
fanno un sacco di sette anni comunque
queste ben ha trovato lo stesso autore
rai non guardate che vi dico dove ho
trovato e col quale dente le zampe
lunghe si sa a 9 punti
vediamo se ce n'è un'altra se abbiamo
finito finito
e allora io ho fatto in totale un totale
di 9 punti
fatemi sapere voi quanti punti avete
fatto così vediamo se avete vinto voi o
se ho vinto io
tra noi due e se volete vedere altre
falle niger stili di queste lasciato un
bel live se questo video come sempre
aggiunge t et simila dai andrò a fare
altri giochi talent sfide assieme che fa
perché mi diverte un sacco anche pavese
perché vi divertite tantissimo se volete
sapere che più degli spiriti cose strane
che sente dentro casa scrivetelo nei
commenti e magari faccio un video che ti
racconto con le cose ma non vi
preoccupate non penso che sia normale
che non è successo niente di grave
fino ad ora comunque era nella sua fa
quattro video che potete vedere quattro
playlist se volete vedere anche un
challenge altri miei video divertenti
altri giochi indovina trova all'errore
cliccate pure su quello che preferite e
buona visione